اذا اردت ان ترحم الناس ابدا برحمه كل شيء
غير الناس
كان حلمي من انا صغير يكون عندي مكان احط
فيه هالحيوانات الصغيره مشان الشارع
السلام عليكم انا محمد علاء رجل قطط في
حلب
[موسيقى]
ب 2014 اشتد القصف على مدينه حلب هاجرت
السكان من المدينه بس طلعوا السكان
الحيوانات يعني هي بتعتمد على البشر انه
تاكل فكنت انا الوحيد
القطط عندي اجوا من كل المنطقه اللي انا
فيها اتجمعوا بالحي عندي
اضطريت كل يوم ادور محلات اللحمه اجمع
بقايا اللحوم وباخذ بقايا اللحم بجيبه معي
على البيت العصر بيكونوا كل الحيوانات عم
تستناني كتير حبيت يعني انه استمر واكافح
اكثر مشان اساعد هالحيوانات
[موسيقى]
اذا اردت ان ترحم الناس ابدا برحمه كل شيء
غير الناس تعرضت للموت اكثر من 100 مره
بمدينه حلب من القصف وانا اقوم بعملي
كسايا
فكنت بتوقع انه بسبب هالحيوانات الله
نجاني حتى استمر معهم اطعميهم طبعا
ساعدوني كتير اصدقائي لالي من سنه 2014
ولحد الان الحمد لله في اصدقاء مسابره على
مساعدتي ودعمي وباي شكل من الاشكال
بتعرفوا تعي تعي نظام منضم يلا اثنين اح
اثنين
اه اثنين اه اثنين
جابوا لي اياها مشلوله ما بتمشي على
ايديها ولا على رجليها كانت بركه بالارض
نحممت طعميها كذا حتى قدرت تمشي على اجرها
وهو صغير من الاتارب
بنغالي مسمينه
من ادلب كمان القصه هي واخواتها فيها لولو
كمان هي واولادها هذا غرغور كان معي بكلّس
كتير انا بكون سعيد وقت بكون كمان قريب
منهم بيعطوني هيك الراحه النفسيه يعني
بيعطوه طاقه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]